If you're looking for a boutique cocktail experience,
head over to Costa,
who just launched their new gin with Charleston Distilling Company
and are whipping up fresh cocktails
to highlight the beautiful product that they've put together.
I personally really like their classic martini with their new gin,
as well as their take on the Salty Dog
with just added a little bit of grapefruit
to bring out all the sweetness and floral notes of the gin.
But the real highlight of the night was when the sommelier let us in
a beautiful shot tasting,
instructing us to take a little shot of the gin,
then have the caviar, let it roll around in our mouth.
Yes, I know.
And then finish off the gin.
I think
I've decided that all shots should be served with a shot of caviar.
Now, if you're saying that you're not a gin drinker,
this is the gin for you. It is sweet and floral and perfectly balanced,
and only available at Costa and at Zero George.
So go there and make sure you get a beautiful, dirty martini.